this video was made possible by
curiositystream
watch an exclusive companion video to
this by signing up for the curiosity
stream nebula bundle deal at
curiositystream.com
wendover ten years ago
in may 2011 adele's rolling in the deep
was topping the billboard charts
the first season of game of thrones was
on its way to becoming a television
phenomenon
osama bin laden had just been killed by
u.s navy seals
and the international olympic committee
was sending letters to national olympic
committees
soliciting bids to host the 32nd running
of the summer
olympic games this moment marked the
start of a decade-long process of
planning and preparation
all leading up to a mere 16 days of
international
sporting competition step two was this
one month later the governor of tokyo
japan announced his city's intention to
submit a bid
in large part to mark their recovery
from the massive 20
000 death earthquake that had devastated
the country mere months before
soon enough madrid istanbul baku and
doha
each submitted bids as well but in the
end
after a two-year evaluation process a
contract was signed between the
international olympic committee
the japanese olympic committee and the
city of tokyo in september 2013.
tokyo would host the 2020 summer
olympic games for an event of this scale
tens of thousands of athletes millions
of spectators and billions of television
viewers
a mere seven year planning period
believe it or not leaves no
time to waste the most watched
television broadcast in existence needs
to be planned
a whole village needs to be constructed
dozens of stadiums and venues need to be
built refurbished or adapted
and one of the world's largest cities
needs to plan for what might be
the busiest three weeks of its existence
to complete this task
tokyo was given this the host city
contract
operational requirements documents
across its 273 pages
this outlines in incredible detail what
the international olympic committee or
ioc
requires from its contractual partner
tokyo in order to complete
the olympics successfully and crucially
consistently with all past
and future games it's essentially the
bible
for olympic organizers the 2015 edition
made for the 2020 games now being held
in 2021
outlines some absolutely minuscule
details
for example tokyo had to install weather
stations at the sites of all
outdoor competition venues three years
prior to the start of the games
in order to collect long-term data to be
used by the ioc to inform their
scheduling of events
the document also establishes some basic
but far-reaching guidelines
such as the fact that the olympics will
last 16 days except for a certain number
of preliminary competitions that
subject to ioc approval can be held
prior to the opening ceremony
it also in a matter of mere paragraphs
outlines
massive asks such as the necessity for
tokyo to book 41
177 hotel rooms for the media marketing
partners future host city
representatives
ioc executives national olympic
committee representatives international
sport federation representatives and
more
this is equivalent to close to half of
all of tokyo's hotel rooms
and it only represents the accommodation
requirements for those actually running
the games
not those competing or spectating the
hotel capacity crunch was such an issue
in fact
that prior to the prohibition of
international spectators due to the
coronavirus pandemic
the city had planned to dock cruise
ships in tokyo bay to serve as
additional temporary hotels
athletes however do not stay in hotels
since the 1932 los angeles games each
host city constructs a dedicated
olympics village to house athletes
far away from the crowds of fans and
hordes of media
now the ioc's operational requirements
set strict standards to assure that
for the most part the 2012 village is
just like the 2020 village
for all practical purposes for example
it has to be within 50 kilometers
31 miles or a 60 minute drive of all
venues
so if any event takes place further from
the main host city
an additional village is constructed
this is especially relevant for the
winter games
with which indoor sports often happen
within the main host city
but outdoor events happen further away
at mountain resorts
for example in the case of the 2014
games a primary village was constructed
in sochi
one additional one was set up at the
rosa couture ski resort where snow
sports events took place
for the summer games in tokyo however
just one village was constructed
and the operational requirements
dictated that it must have the capacity
for 16 000 people
so it operates at the scale of a small
town
the requirements also dictate that rooms
must be at least 97 square feet or 9
meters in size
or 129 square feet or 12 meters with
double rooms
and even outline the required contents
in addition the village must have an
olympics merchandise store
a bank photo store hair salon florist
dry cleaning shop
travel agent post office and more
typically
mcdonald's also sets up a temporary
restaurant in the village for the games
which is like any mcdonald's except that
its menu has no prices
the company provides athletes with food
for free in exchange for the publicity
it inevitably attracts
lastly according to the operational
requirements document
the village even must have a designated
place of mourning
now constructing brand new dedicated
venues such as the village
for the purposes of a 16-day event quite
obviously
presents problems while in decades past
cities were essentially willing to throw
any amount of money at the games
and sometimes ran at hundreds of percent
over budget due to a belief that the
publicity they attracted was invaluable
taxpayers and therefore governments are
increasingly skeptical of the value that
the games
truly provides for a city and country
there are plenty of horror stories of
places like turin italy the host of the
2006 games whose village now sits
derelict and is inhabited by squatters
essentially a complete waste of money
from the perspective of the city
and therefore its taxpayers there are
also however
cases like that of sydney which
redeveloped its olympics park into a
true
neighborhood it's now home to upscale
hotels restaurants and housing complexes
and hosts nearly 6 000 events both large
and small each
year altogether having seen the horror
stories
the olympics are becoming less
attractive for cities
in decades past plenty of cities would
bid to host each olympics
but now there are situations like paris
2024 or los angeles 2028 where cities
are awarded the games effectively by
default
having faced zero competition in the
bidding process
for those that do host the games though
cost consciousness has increased
dramatically
and they're now trying to craft their
venue strategy closer to that
of sydney rather than turin in tokyo
three categories of olympic venues are
being used
the first is temporary with certain
events such as canoeing climbing beach
volleyball or sailing
there's little prospect that the city
can redevelop the venue into something
self-sustaining after the games
so they either set up spectator and
media facilities at existing sporting
facilities that just lack the scale to
host an olympic event
or they set up an entirely new temporary
venue for more popular sports that
require less specialized facilities
however
tokyo is using pre-existing venues
around the city
for example with table tennis which
requires little infrastructure
the tokyo metropolitan gymnasium is
being used just as it was during the
1964 tokyo olympics for gymnastics
with certain events however the tokyo
organizers believed it was
actually worth it to build a brand new
venue
swimming and diving events for example
will happen at the brand new olympics
aquatic center
this is often the case at summer games
swimming and diving are typically some
of the most
watched sports at the olympics despite
mediocre popularity as a spectator sport
outside the games
that means cities often lack aquatics
venues with the scale necessary for
olympic events
so this is one of the venues more often
built as new
at the 2016 rio de janeiro games a
temporary aquatic stadium was built
while at london 2012 beijing 2008 sydney
2000
and plenty more new permanent facilities
were created
now with each of these new permanent
venues the bureau of olympic
and paralympic games tokyo 2020
preparation
had to justify their long-term value
beyond the games to the government
and public therefore they released this
document it outlines the core of their
development strategy
they want to create not only effective
venues but an appealing neighborhood
certainly following the model of sydney
2000 so that they can consider
any money spent an investment rather
than a cost
with each of these new venues such as
the new olympic aquatic center for
example
they've published a detailed post games
plan
through redeveloping the venue into both
a long-term competition venue and a
community recreation center
the bureau believes they can attract a
million visitors per year after the
games
and while they project the facility to
run at a loss it's one small enough to
be comparable with other similar public
recreation centers created outside of
the context of the olympics
some of the other venues such as the
aryake arena to be used for volleyball
are expected to turn a profit after the
games so altogether
if projections are accurate these new
venues won't be a long-term financial
burden to the city
and its taxpayers now of course
like with anything regarding the
olympics each of the 42 venues need to
follow a
sprawling set of strict standards for
example they each need to have the
olympics flag
and respective international sporting
federation flag flying in a conspicuous
spot
they need to have a full backup power
system for all broadcast
media technology sport and security
operations
while their lighting systems must be
split into two sections with independent
power supplies for each
so that events can go on even through
power failure
in terms of the actual sporting
facilities however
these are each subject to the standards
of the respective ioc recognized
international sports federation
for example olympic rowing is managed by
the international rowing federation
which recommends 531 feet or 162 meters
of course width
and requires 2 162 meters or 7
126 feet of length their standards get
plenty more specific though
they specify the intricacies of the
course buoy system outline where
advertising banners can go detail the
location construction and operation of
timing huts
and much much more each olympic event is
essentially the pinnacle of its sport
so the international federations are
heavily involved
of course the olympics are a made for
television
event while millions of spectators do
typically watch the games in person
billions watch on tv in fact
73 of the olympics total revenue comes
from television rights alone
they simply would not happen in their
modern form if not for their massive
television audience
so perhaps the most important facility
of all is this
the international broadcast center in
tokyo this facility is constructed in
tokyo big site
the country's largest convention center
and is run by the olympics broadcasting
services or obs
now for the longest time broadcasting
operations were something that the
international olympic committee would
contract out to a third party but in
advance of the 2008 beijing olympics
obs was established to act as the host
broadcaster for
all future games now like with most
large sporting events
you won't see cameras from nbc bbc
eurosport and all the other national
broadcasters that carry the events on tv
actually at each event that's because
obs is responsible for
filming and producing each event and
then they provide produced feeds to each
broadcaster
who acts as their customer while nbc for
example
might have reporters and commentators at
each event to augment the obs feeds
they don't actually film the sporting
events themselves
now obs is a standalone independent
company
set up by the ioc to fulfill these
broadcast functions
while typically it has some 166
employees
this balloons up to 8 100 during the
games
mostly comprised of the operational
staff filming and producing the
television feeds
its ultimate task in tokyo is to create
9 500 hours of content
more than with any prior olympic games
to accomplish this it has deployed some
1049 cameras
and 3600 microphones across tokyo's 42
venues these are cut together into
produced world feeds in dedicated
broadcast compounds at each venue
before being delivered to here the
international broadcast center
from one month before the games until
its conclusion this is a
24 7 operation and much like the
olympics village
operates like a small town with
restaurants coffee shops bars a medical
center
bank convenience store dry cleaners and
even a massage room
many of obs facilities at the
international broadcast center
deal with the technical aspects of
taking the world feeds of which as many
as 64 are produced simultaneously in the
case of day two of the games
and disseminating these out to all the
different rights holding broadcasters
around the world
however in addition to television
production
much of the purpose of this facility is
to act as a workspace for all the
journalists from around the world who
have traveled to the games
during the olympics one of obs main
functions is essentially
as a landlord they manage the
international broadcast center
and rent out space to different
broadcasters to serve as their
workspaces
a private office in the center comes in
units of 270 square feet or 25 square
meters
and in the case of tokyo costs some five
thousand and eleven dollars per unit for
the duration of the games
of course though there are plenty of up
charges
even once a broadcaster is paid to rent
a space two normal wall plugs will cost
them 876 dollars
and the obs rate card even includes the
option to purchase a power strip for 27
meanwhile getting a dedicated 100
megabit per second ethernet plug
to provide more stable internet than the
free wi-fi costs broadcasters 19
04 obs also sells broadcasters a digital
data feed
giving real-time access to results
schedules medals records news biography
statistics and more
this is what ultimately gets repackaged
into for example
the real-time results you'll see on the
nbc or the bbc
websites finally obs ratecard includes
options to outfit a broadcaster's
private office with a walkie-talkie for
438 dollars
small folding table for 67 microwave for
105 dollars
and electric kettle for 23. with 6 000
accredited journalists awarded access to
the tokyo games
it's as much a job to manage them as the
athletes and
while procuring an electric kettle for
an la time sports writer might seem like
a trivial task
it makes the journalists jobs easier and
doing so plays a tiny but present part
in helping the olympics run smoothly now
ultimately while there are plenty of big
decisions required in planning the
olympics
there are a few small ones for the most
part the host city's jobs are just to
follow an incredibly detailed set of
instructions
they spend the better part of a decade
doing exactly that
but the ultimate goal of the 2020 games
is to make an event that's just as
successful
and runs largely the same as the games
of 2016 2012
2008 or any year before the goal
is consistency and therefore the task
while enormous
is strictly prescribed that doesn't mean
it's straightforward though
every page of this document represents
an incredible amount of work
a single line might become an
individual's job for years
and then actually putting that together
combining the tasks as small as placing
the right flag in a venue
with those as large as building an
entirely new stadium
is what makes for a truly successful and
impressive
event as anyone knows by now
the 2020 tokyo olympic games are
actually happening
in 2021 of course taking one of the
world's
largest events and postponing it by a
year mere months before
after a decade of preparation is an
incredible feat
i didn't have time to cover that in this
video but for those interested
i made a companion video about the
subject and put it on
nebula nebula of course is always home
to our normal videos early and ad-free
exclusive companion videos such as this
and big budget nebula originals
and it's not only us but also tons of
your favorite educational creators
such as real engineering mkbhd and
lindsey ellis
of course what makes nebula even better
is the best way to get access to it
the curiosity stream bundle deal that's
because curiosity stream is home to an
endless catalog of top quality
non-fiction shows and documentaries
such as the tulip bubble this is a
really well-made documentary about one
of my favorite pieces of historical
trivia
the time when tulip bulbs were sold
quite literally for their weight in gold
and how the financial markets
surrounding them demonstrated one of the
first stories of boom and bust
so you can get nebula and curiosity
stream together
including tons of video content that
you'll actually watch
for an unbelievable price just 14.79
a year with the current sale at
curiositystream.com
wendover that truly has to be the best
deal in streaming
and signing up helps support not only
wendover but all these
independent creators so head to
curiositystream.com
wendover